this is your reminder that the BBC has
yet to address the consistent
transphobic leanings in its news
coverage and while the team behind
Doctor Who is not connected to this in
any way since this is a BBC owned
property I'm going to keep pointing it
out until the problem gets resolved
links in a pin comment below if you
don't know what I'm talking about I'll
stop saying it when it stops being a
problem boy have I got a lot to cover
with this one let's do
it
[Music]
[Applause]
okay you know what I know it wasn't the
exact same suit as it used to be in but
props to David ten are still fitting in
a suit that skinny
because I can't anymore
granted I've had more specific changes
to my body than he would have had in the
years anyways the star Beast first of
the Doctor Who specials to Mark the 60th
anniversary first experience above any
extended length with the 14th doctor the
return of David Tenant we have the
return of Donna we have the introduction
of a bunch of new characters we have the
integration of a creature that has been
known within the Deep lore of Doctor Who
for some time with the Meep there's a
lot there's a lot a lot here I have no
idea how long this is going to run and
the review is probably going to be a
little bit scattershot I should also
give you a um spoiler warning up at the
front end like if you haven't seen it
you should I'll do kind of a brief
synopsis at the front end but like then
I'm just going to start talking about
whatever I decide to do next and it's
probably going to be all over the place
but we have the 14th doctor show up and
immediately runs into Donna we
immediately establish Donna's daughter
of
Rose um who I like a lot we'll come back
to her uh we uh encounter the husband
Shawn who we have met before but didn't
really get to know I like him a lot I
like I don't I don't know if I'll
remember to bring him up later so I'm
going to say this now what I really love
about Shawn is just he's the epitome of
okay well let's roll with it something
smells nice T my dress meet me I figure
that's the kind of person you have to be
to have a successful relationship with
Donna and it works it works really well
and it's just nice to see especially
because so often in uh the more recent
era of Doctor Who since the reboot
relationships that companions have had
have often
felt interruptive to things they felt
like an intrusion in some way not all of
them I actually think better of Danny
pink than most and they did actually
integrate Rory and Amy as a couple but
often times romantic entanglements of
the companions feel like why does this
need to be here and like you don't get
enough of a sense of the relationship to
even really get why they're together
here no absolutely he doesn't get that
much screen time but I get it and I see
why they work we have a return of
Donna's mother Sylvia she gets
reestablished now of course the doctor
running into Donna is throwing him off a
bit because as we get a full reminder of
at the start so this is very clearly
being set up as a jumping on point it's
it it's all presented in a way that
feels very look here's the bullet points
that you need if this is where you're
starting there's a whole bunch of stuff
you can go back and check out on a
completely different platform if you're
in the US but um but here's there's a
bunch of other stuff you can check out
that'll go into all this but here's the
bullet points here's what you need let's
go I think that was a solid way to start
and so we have a crash ship that Donna
Miss misses and I kind of I kind of love
that they're sticking with that like
that daed just by Quirk of Fate misses
every there's a spaceship burning up on
re-entry directly behind her and she's
down here messing with boxes and
restacking
things yeah yeah like that's we know
that's what we know that's what her life
is like and I like that it establishes
that it kind of continues to be that so
we've got all that and of course from
the from an escape pod from that ship we
have the Meep now as I alluded to before
the Meep is actually kind of a deep cut
the Meep originates from uh Comics I
believe that were in Doctor Who magazine
they originate in some for in some comic
form so that's where both the Meep and
the Wrath Warriors that are hunting the
Meep um all originate from so my big
question going into this was is this
going to canonize the original comic um
uh appearance of these figures or is it
going to adapt them the difference would
have been determined by is the doctor
going to recognize them or is the doctor
not going to know what the deal with the
Wrath Warriors and the Meep is initially
it was the latter which means this is
adapting the comic Works rather than
continuing directly on from them which
is probably the safer thing to do cuz
you know you can get away with with
canonizing baked finish canonizing the
comics is probably a lot Messier so just
choosing to adapt it that was probably a
good call I mean the general
relationship Doctor Who and since its
Revival has had with the extraneous
media be it um big finish be it Comics
be it novels is basically if it doesn't
contradict what's in the show you can
consider it Canon but we reserve the
right to uh contradict it or adapt it
for the first time for the show at a
later date I mean they did it with this
they did it with the big Finnish um
audio Jubilee which created DC back in
series 1 they did did it with uh Paul
Cornell's uh book which was the basis
for human nature and uh family of blood
which was uh initially a novel about the
Seventh Doctor but regardless it's kind
of nice seeing them pull from those
sources again cuz that that was largely
something done during uh rtd's initial
era Russell T Davies who's running the
show and ran it during the initial
Revival and is now doing so again so
it's kind of nice to to have that
assurance that like he willing to dip
into these sources again uh when Steven
Moffett ran the show he didn't really
seem to do that too much at least not to
my memory nothing that stood out heavily
uh at any rate and chel didn't seem to
do it at all now it's not automatically
a good thing but it was something that I
didn't necessarily expect to ever come
back and I kind of like that it has here
so we have the Meep uh the Meep pleads
to Rose um you know this whole thing of
like oh they're after the Meep and you
know being all cute and snuggly and um
suddenly we have possessed unit soldiers
who are appear to be after the Meep but
also the Wrath Warriors are after the
Meep and eventually the reveal being the
Meep is a vicious dictatorial
monster who has possessed a whole bunch
of of unit soldiers so we we get that
twist which I knew was coming because I
knew enough about the Meep to know that
was going to happen but I imagine it was
probably kind of fun uh for folks who
didn't know um I I mean I can't speak
from the position of not knowing I
imagine a decent number of them would
have guessed at some point but I feel
like it's paced and built well and then
it's just a matter of dealing with the
Meep before the Meep gets into the
rocket that it came in and that thing
has a takeoff mechanism that will
basically destroy all of London in order
to power itself back up into space which
yeah okay that's that's a legit threat
and Donna is getting dragged along
through this Rose is getting dragged
along through a chunk of this and
there's the concern about Donna
remembering because of what happened to
her back um with the ending of series 4
that she'd had the consciousness of a
Time Lord poured into her and if she
remembers that's too much for one person
it's going to basically burn her from
the inside out and so we've got all
these things and here's our adventure I
like the tone I like the tone on this
thing a lot it is it is light enough but
it does hit proper emotional moments and
weights especially
around the doctor and Donna and just
well the doctor in general just
reencountering these people and having
these moments and like so there's a
moment referencing wil who doesn't
appear in this episode I'm kind of
expecting to show up in the next one uh
the late uh Bernard cribbons did shoot I
believe everything that they needed from
him before he passed away but we'll see
if they do actually include it but I
like I do enjoy just the references that
it turns out he's he's basically in a at
housing provided by unit she's looking
after to well brilliant brilliant I love
the idea that that unit is just going to
take care of him cuz I mean like old
Soldier yes veteran but beyond that like
for what he did for the doctor like yeah
no we'll take guys's 95 we'll take care
of him don't worry I just like that I
like the doctor's reaction to it
actually let me back up I had kind of
briefly mentioned that my thoughts on
this version of the opening credit theme
was like it's very series 4 version it
it wasn't really anything new which in
of itself is fine but how well it was
going to work for me was going to kind
of depend on the visuals that went along
with it this is great this feels more
open it feels grander it feels like more
of a spectacle it looks more wondrous
and if you're going to go with something
with definitive visuals as opposed to
say what happened during chimel and jod
Whitaker's era which was more abstract
which I did also really like but if
you're not going to go abstract and
you're going to go with definitive
visuals I love the Grandeur and the
Splendor of this and they've tried to in
integrate like the sense of the greater
Universe in some of these opening titles
before they did it towards the end of
Matt Smith's era and it it didn't quite
click for me then but it really does now
I love these opening credits I'll be
curious to see if they keep them um or
if they alter them when we get the
switch to shiwa I and I'll say right now
I'm going to wonder whether that's also
going to be the case for the Sonic
Screwdriver and for the tartis interior
I'm assuming not the Taris interior
because that would be a big expense to
only use for three specials and then
completely redesign but I'll come back
to the Taris interior but since I
brought it up uh why don't we talk
about the Sonic
Screwdriver I like the New Uses we see
for this and I say that as someone who
has felt in the past that the Sonic kind
of became to allpurpose I I felt that
especially during 11's tenure when it
was Matt Smith but one of the things I
really liked about um Christopher eelen
and the original DAV tenant R was that
it felt like it had a number of very
specific functions pretty high number of
specific ones and this feels a little
bit more like that but even though we're
getting this whole new thing where like
it can kind of draw thing is like it's a
map or it's a shield that could have
been overpowered that could have been
like oh great there's there's a
massively useful utility function for
this thing but the thing is like it
takes him a while to do it so it can't
be thrown up quickly and I think that's
a good way to Nerf what would otherwise
be too useful an ability for him to just
have in his pocket um so I think it's
and like really the only reason it works
here is because the possessed unit
soldiers and the Wrath Warriors are too
busy shooting at each other to focus on
the doctor and uh the noble family so
that that works for me because while I
think the functioning of itself like
that's that's kind of too useful and too
allp purpose for the doctor to have but
he can't throw it up quickly so I think
that is going to be a good explanation
for why hopefully we don't see him abuse
this as a function of the screwdriver in
future so that's the kind of thing I
like from it like I did appreciate
during jod Whitaker's era that it was
primarily used just as a scanner I liked
pairing it back down to that you know it
just sometimes open doors and it mainly
scans stuff I did like that simplifying
but if we're going to add more functions
to it especially if they seem super
useful I think it's a good idea to give
it a downside and having it take a while
to draw this thing in the air that's a
suitable downside you know it's it's
balancing your mechanics so one
character uh in the game isn't
completely op and I decided to go with
video game terms there for a second I
don't know why we're going to move on
I'm going to reiterate right now that I
I would have really liked if they had
David Tenant used his natural Scottish
accents in this form as as the doctor it
because one of the concerns that I've
had about this doctor is that it is just
going to feel like the 10th doctor again
and it's not going to feel like its own
distinct entity that has to figure out
why it looks like an older one but this
really does just feel like him and from
a Nostalgia standpoint that's not the
worst thing in the world but from a
storytelling and like mapping the
overall journey of the doctor and the
way that they're different like it's
disappointing I I would was really kind
of hoping for more to distinguish him
and make it clear how he's different
other than just the experiences he's had
since the last time he had this face and
right now so far at least this mostly
feels like the only difference is the
stuff he's been through personality-wise
seems pretty much like the same guy
which Dynamic wise in terms of bouncing
off of Dawn and slipping back into that
Dynamic yeah I do get why they went that
way they didn't want to alter a love
dynamic between doctor and companion so
I I do kind of get it but I still find
it a little bit disappointing uh there
um okay something else I need to address
so we have a uh sort of a higher up in
unit who appears in this uh who is a
wheelchair user I do like her I actually
especially like that early on they have
this whole thing where like the soldiers
are going to to check out the upper
portion of this rocket and they have to
go up these stairs and one of them just
looks and goes oh U sorry and her
response is just like don't wait for me
go do your job which is perfect sorry
about the stairs but J says to go in
immediately don't make me the problem
just get in there and also it becomes a
narrative uh necessity that she not be
up there with the rest of them because
they all get possessed and she doesn't
so the other thing I need to address in
regards to this is if you saw my earlier
video about the whole thing with Davos
and what was done with him and the
children in need special one of the
things I mentioned there is my
preference to the kind of alteration
that that RTD may have done with Davis
again I did a whole video on it but
short version being like Davis is a
character traditionally heavily scarred
and in a Mobility Aid and for the
purposes of that short he was neither
now depending on how it's done moving
forward that can be treated as like a
one-off thing or it could be how he is
depicted going forward there's wiggle
room for both to happen but one of the
things I mentioned when I talked about
that was my preference to trying to um
just fix a problematic Trope uh the
problematic Trope
being evil uh people with clear visible
disabilities and I I I I don't have the
time to to parse all of that again I did
a whole video on disability
representation so if you're confused as
as to that go check out that video I
don't eat up my comments with that
question here as to why that's a problem
just understand it's a thing um so my
preference to just altering a character
more often than not is to provide
counter examples which this does and
what I'm hoping that means is that um
RTD or anyone else won't feel the need
for the uh unscarred and bipedal version
of davus to be the new default because
we can't do we can't lean into the Trope
we were trying to avoid I'm hoping that
the presence of a counter example like
this uh this woman who's near the who's
kind of heading up the unit group I'm
hoping that that's what they'll lean
into more because this is exactly what I
said is the better way to do it provide
counter examples so that the only people
using Mobility AIDS aren't all monsters
so it was nice to see her but even
beyond that I'm sure some people have
and will cry you know oh it's just forc
diversity and it's woke and it's like I
haven't watched any of the people who
are going to say that I know they are
though and I there's other stuff
particularly around Rose I'm sure
they're going to freak out I don't need
to see it I know what they say they
always say the same stuff uh we'll get
to Rose but I think I think she's just a
good character and I think she's well
utilized and I think her disability is
integrated interestingly and into both
the character and the narrative like she
doesn't make a big deal out of it the
soldier kind of makes a bigger deal out
of it than she does she and being in
unit she's built utility into this thing
that makes perfect sense to me I like
her I hope she shows up again I'm a
little bit torn later on with sort of
how the meeps plan uh gets undone in
Reverse cuz like there's these cracks
forming and like first of all we have
the highly convenient thing that all
these cracks appear to be you branching
out and going down the streets and
obeying that so we're not seeing houses
split in half and then when the whole
thing's reversed not only is like is
there no longer this fiery Doom coming
up from these CRA the cracks actually
close themselves it it feels a little
clean it feels a little just okay why'
you why'd you have it be that much
damage in the first place if you're just
going to undo it immediately which is
something RTD has done a couple times um
but that having been said I will kind of
take it as a little bit of um pallet
cleanser from the fact that chibal
during the jod Whitaker era had a
tendency to just cause a lot of damage
and not deal with it so like if you're
not going to deal with it I suppose
reversing it is better than just
forgetting that you destroyed a huge
chunk of the universe and never
addressing it again which is what shibel
did so I it I it didn't bother me as
much as it might have I think only
because we were coming off the back of
the era of an era that handled
collateral damage and destruction from
the from the villains worse than this so
I don't love it but it is better so
let's talk about Rose first of all Rose
is a trans character played by a
transactor
good that's the Baseline thank you um so
already off to a solid start um the ways
in which it is established that she is
trans I am 50/50 on there is one scene
that I think is handled beautifully and
there's one that I'm like I'd rather you
hadn't done that and it's not again not
the worst thing in the world but like I
don't know if RTD consulted any uh trans
people um to like do a pass on the
script but here's the note I would have
given if I had been asked for my input
specifically on this aspect um I love
how absolutely deadset
supportive Rose's entire family is the
scene that I mentioned that I think is
handled incredibly well that establishes
Rosa's trans is with um Donna's mother
because Donna's mother not in Rose's
presence but once Rose is gone it's like
second guessing her interactions you
know using using a term like gorgeous is
that too stereotypically feminine and I
reinforcing stereotypes is is that what
she wants to hear and like that
uncertainty I think especially from
somebody of her generation I've seen
like she wants to do it right but she
has a lot of self-confidence issues
about whether or not she is doing it
right and I think that scene rang very
true for especially older members uh you
know older Generations who want to be
supportive but feel awward about it I
thought that was very well done I just
get so clumsy I know so do I the scene
leading into it with the boys on the
street yelling at
Rose I don't think it was wrong to
include them yelling because that is
regrettably also true to the trans
experience um in both the US and the UK
just a lot of harassment and a lot of
nonsense I really would have preferred
that they hadn't yelled Rose's birth
name I'm not going to say dead name cuz
we don't know for certain if she
considers it that like for example I go
by Vera my birth name is Nathaniel I
don't consider it a dead name I do still
use it in some situations and it doesn't
make me dysphoric the dead name
specifically means you're dysphoric
about it and you don't want to hear it
anymore it seems like rose probably
leans closer to dead name but we don't
know for sure so I'm just opting to call
it birth name I really would have
rathered though that we hadn't heard
like they could have yelled hey dude
nice dress or oh bro cool makeup like
cuz to be honest that's the kind of
stuff I get in my comments by the dozens
literally every morning every morning I
come on here and I have to spend the
first 15 minutes or so of my day
clearing out those comments so like you
could go oh it's generic and unoriginal
yeah so are transphobes so you want to
be accurate to the experience that works
now would kids who are trying to be
transphobic who know her birth name
would they have yelled at at her yes but
the reason I would rather it wasn't
there is I don't like giving ammunition
to jerk viewers who are now going to
dead Name the character just to be
jackasses like they were going to
misgender her regardless but now they
also have a name to stick to
it that's ammunition you didn't need to
give them and I say ammunition as if it
actually matters like in my view the
opinions of such people don't matter
they legitimately do not but I still
think that was unnecessary I've had
similar thoughts in other cases like
there was a there was a comic I read a
couple years ago that had a non-binary
character and I really like that but
what bugged me was at one point in the
story it was confirmed what that
character's uh gender assigned at Birth
was and that was really disappointing
because especially in the comic book
medium where you don't have a voice to
queue off of and it's just an artistic
rendering they really had the
opportunity to have a non-binary
character that the uh that that any jerk
audience members couldn't accurately
Miss gender cuz they don't know what the
character's gender assigned to birth was
and because it's just an artistic
rendering you can't be sure character
was fairly androgynous and it just
bummed me out that they kind of lost
that ability to to lean into that and I
kind of have similar feelings here like
it's not wrong that we found out what
her birth name was but it also wasn't
necessary and I would kind of rather it
wasn't there I've spent longer on this
point than I wanted to but it was one of
those things I that kind of required
explanation so don't take the amount of
time I spent talking about this to be
reflective of how um deeply I feel about
it I actually don't think it's that big
a deal it's just a small note that's
actually kind of the sort of thing
that's going to happen a bit with rose
um I have I have a lot of opinions on
trans representation shock of shocks so
I I might Linger on some of this more
then it is actually reflective of how
prominent these feelings are are for me
in regards to the thing
overall um
but just in general the supportive
family the way she's portrayed you know
the other uh the the younger kid from
The Block is who's just you know calling
a rose and getting all excited it was
great I'll be curious to see if they
bring that boy back because he gets a
little bit more prominence than I think
was required for his use here which
seemed to primarily be just have a
character we recognize reacting to the
cracks coming down the street and
whatnot that my all we get from him but
who knows we'll see so the doctor
Donna the doctor unlocking this aspect
of Donna first of all I like that it has
already started leaking through like her
running back to help him is because that
instinct is still there like it's it's
buried she can't remember most of it but
leaks out little bits and I love that
the first thing she does when he unlocks
all her memories is get mad at him for
the lingering sense of the doctor's uh
moral compass that was stuck in her that
that was still there gave her the
impulse to give away all the lottery
money I love that her first reaction is
to be pissed at him for that I gave it
away to be like you so I could be kind
so I could be nice so I could be helpful
un that's very Donna cuz like while the
giving it all away like it gave me a
warning feeling there was there was part
of me that like would she though and
this basically establishes like no no
she wouldn't fully within her own
faculties and not influenced by this
background aspect of the doctor that was
in her head no she wouldn't have and she
knows that and she's
ticked 166 million pound yes Donna
destruction of London oh I'll show you
destru mate that oh that was really good
and just I get why the Dr Donna kind of
can't be a long-term continuing thing
because that basically gives us two
active doctors and one that's
permanently on Earth why would the
doctor ever have to come back to save
Earth again if the doctor Don is right
here like I get why she can't stay that
way but I do still really enjoy when she
is the Dr Donna and bouncing off of
tenant like so rapid fire it's so much
fun I feel good about
half of the solution so that Donna does
not die and I I was like I was fairly
confident she wasn't going to die
because there's more specials and I've
seen like behind the scenes footage that
seem to indicate some scenes that have
not been shown in this yet
but I got genuinely nervous and I got
choked up seeing that she might that
felt like a genuine threat
and when she didn't and we get the
reveal of rose that basically divided
the metac crisis so that it was not as
severe but it was carried in both of
them I actually really like that as a
solution I think that's quite clever and
it's something that I I wouldn't have
thought of obviously the doctor didn't
think of it he realizes what's happened
but I I like that I think that's clever
and also giving Rose
this wonderful affirming
Shining Moment that you know she she is
different not just for being trans but
for everything that her mother passed on
to
her she's different she's special like
Donna is even though Donna didn't think
she was special for so so so long and I
I like that we then have the further and
and and also some of the specific lines
that feel slightly muddled so like
there's the non-binary
thing we are binary she's not because
the doctors male and female and neither
I'm and again
I one of two things happened
here either
RTD miscommunicated something or
doesn't fully understand nonbinary and I
don't want to accuse him of one or the
other
but here's the here's the reason like
that line I don't have an inherent
problem with it and actually especially
as a callback to Donna's whole binary
binary binary binary thing from the end
of series 4 like
binary non binary B I get the impulse to
do something with that when you have uh
a a trans character but the thing is
everything about Rose's depiction
indicated her as being a binary trans
woman and what I mean by that is um the
gender binary if you aren't familiar
with this concept is man woman now
non-binary is everything either in
between or separate from so people whose
sense of gender does not firmly hit one
or the other
and this could be a whole other topic
I'm not going to get into it right now
but like no it's not just about wanting
to wear gender neutral clothes or
wanting to be Butch if you're a woman
like it is about an actual sense of self
so I need you to roll with that but
non-binary is a thing it is people who
fall somewhere in the middle um gender
fluid which is what I am is a form of
non-binary because yes sometimes I do
feel very very fem other times it's
somewhere in the middle and it meanders
my sense of self does not stay put um
then there's also a gender people who
feel like I gender I I hardly know her I
I don't like know I don't think I have
one and so like there's multiple forms
of non-binary but the thing is Rose has
shown here really appears to be a binary
transwoman moving from one part of the
gender binary which again gender is not
actually a binary just go with the
terminology here moving from one part of
the binary from a sign gender of birth
of man to woman that is a binary
transition so she's not non-binary at
least as you depict her here if she is
non-binary you did not establish that
and I think one quick line that could of
if that was the intention I don't know
if it was but if it was one quick line
that could have covered for that would
have been when um Sylvia uh Donna's
mother was kind of flubbing a little bit
um maybe with the pronouns or the name
Donna could have said you know it's also
okay to call her they if that's better
for you and so you could have been like
no that's even more confusing cuz I'm
used to that being plural and again not
to make a joke out of it but just to
acknowledge why it's difficult for her
um I think that that could have been the
chance to easily and quickly establish
that she is a non-binary transperson but
you didn't establish that so the
non-binary line sticks out
as
misapplied I think again I'm not I can't
be certain of what his actual intent was
but as depicted it's not quite Landing
right
um but there's that oh I do want to say
this I'm impressed with the fact that
RTD managed to put in a did you just
assume pronouns joke and it actually
worked cuz that joke pretty much never
works it's largely done by um by the
right to make fun of trans people oh did
I assume your pronounce but even when
I've heard people uh who are trans
themselves or trying to be supportive of
trans people make a version of that joke
it always comes off really bad to me
this one I actually think worked I think
that actually worked as a joke because
not only um did Rose be like did you
just assume pronouns but the doctor's
reaction wasn't to roll his eyes and be
like H it was like oh no that's a good
point you're assuming he as a
pronoun true yes sorry good point are
you he or she or they and I also like
that the Meep just says the MEEP the
Meep only has proper noun there are no
pronouns for the meep My Chosen pronoun
is the definite article I am always the
Meep oh I do that which also makes it a
valid observation from Rose because it
actually applied to how the Meep talks
about the Meep and how the Meep wants
other people to talk about the Meep um
you could argue it's a Neo pronoun I
think it's just proper noun across the
board doesn't make use of pronouns but I
was impressed RTD made that joke
actually work and function so Props to
that um the one other thing uh coming
back not only to Rose but also to to
Rose and Donna the the dispersing of the
sort of Time Lord Essence the idea of
just letting it
go that really seems too
easy and the the lines associated with
it also
feel not fully thought through and again
I'm sure these are some lines that um
certain kinds of pundits are losing
their freaking Minds over but you know
the line's about we've got all that
power but there is a way to get rid of
it something a male presenting Time Lord
will never understand I guess I'm just
kind of
like I don't think that has anything to
do with anything um and again if if
there was a specific inent intent behind
a line like that it's not well
communicated
I
think I think the impression is that
just the way that the doctor
particularly when the doctor is a man
tends to
think is a little bit too rigid to have
the uh the sort of mental Mobility to
come up with a slightly more outof
the-box solution which to be fair Donna
also didn't come up with on her own
because Donna
when she first became the Dr Dawn in
series 4 it's not like she suggested
it's not like she knew that this was a
possibility either so it feels like it's
meant to be like the additional
understanding of you aren't stuck as one
thing and you can just change who you
are to become something that is healthy
for you if what you are currently is not
that that understanding from Rose added
to the sort of split of the Dr Donna
that might be what gives gives the idea
of like you just let it go kind of like
how Rose would have had to just let go
of whatever
masculinity she felt burdened by I think
that might have been the the idea or at
least that's the mental work that I'm
doing to come up with a version of this
interaction that fully clicks cuz when
it happened I was kind of like wait what
I think that's just the the dialogue
back and forth might have needed some
fine tuning might have needed another
pass just for Clarity cuz it seems
written for more Punchy lines but the
punchier lines aren't communicating the
idea assuming I'm even right about what
the idea is if the idea was meant to be
something else altogether then it really
needed some clarification cuz even my
attempt to to sort of um head Cannon
what it is that's going on if if even
that is wrong then okay I really don't
know what you were doing and that need
to be more properly communicated I'm not
going to like go off on a whole thing
and like uh
making it all this gender stuff
like I do think there is a way that
tying it to a um you know a trans
understanding of existence that like you
don't have to hold on to this stuff you
can just let it go I think there is a
way to make that idea work it just isn't
quite pulled off here but that it didn't
weigh me down to the point that I'm like
uh God I wasn't rolling my eyes I was
just slightly confused and again I feel
like um if there wasn't and maybe there
was I don't know but if there wasn't a
uh transperson consulted for these
specific aspects of the story that maybe
there should have been um maybe there
was I don't know um but uh overall I
think the finding a way to give Donna
her memories back but also remove the
fact that it was going to kill her was
nice to see like I have said in the past
that there was a beautiful tragedy to
her exit in series 4 and I stand bu that
but I'm also now at an age where I'm
like okay tragedy can have Beauty to it
but C could we could we have more happy
endings please and this gives me that
and I'm happy for it I'm a little bit
annoyed that Rose was not allowed to go
in the Tardis I suspect the reason is
just like the adventure for the next
episode is meant to just be the doctor
and Donna but like I'm a little annoyed
like you could have at least let her in
to see the thing uh even if you were
then going to shoe her out before the
whole thing with the coffee which I did
laugh I I did legitimately crack like it
that's a cheap joke but dang it it
worked um so the Tardis interior took me
a little bit to get used to cuz I've
seen the Tardis this white before back
in classic era Doctor Who but when it's
been this white that room the control
room was small significantly so seeing
it that expansive and that white made it
feel kind of empty in a way that I'm not
sure I love like the Tardis interior has
been this big before the tartis interior
for eckleson and Tennis first run was a
bit cramped and that worked that was
fine but it felt bigger uh with Matt
Smith his initial design but it was just
loaded with quirky stuff and then it had
the redesign and when it was Smith in
there it was okay but then when Peter
kali's doctor was in there there were
like bookshelves and a bust of bethoven
and a chalkboard and like it there was
stuff in it it didn't feel empty and
then the 13th doctor's ttis interior was
just so busy I never really had a solid
sense of how big the thing even was to
be completely honest but this right now
as presented like we're getting a good
look at it I'm hoping there will be
stuff in it because it just feels kind
of empty that having been said I like
that the round things light up in color
that's a cool touch I dig that and that
did help once I saw it I'm like oh okay
so it won't be all white all the time we
can get you know some mood lighting
basically for lack of a better way to
put it in here and I'm down for that I
just it's for how big it is it feels
kind of empty that said seeing David
Tenant run around in it was both
thrilling and exhausting I'm watching
him going oh I would lose my breath so
quickly trying to run that excitedly
around there oh I'm old now
here we are couple of quick things I
like that the two wrath Warriors who die
get acknowledged they get named and then
they get recognized again at the end
sergeant zth and Constable Z gave their
lives because RTD did have a problem
with treating the loss of non-human life
kind of flippantly during his initial
run he didn't do it all the time but it
happens sometimes and I like that it
doesn't happen here also random question
was anyone else's sound mix like a
little bit off I had to turn the
subtitles on the dialogue got drowned
found out sometimes was that just me let
me know I think I think I've touched on
everything in terms of the specific so
broad thoughts this was fun this had the
energy that I wanted RTD to bring back
this is a bit nostalgic but I'm while
I've said I really hope that RTD doesn't
just try and bring back you know try and
recapture The Glory Days of his original
run and does some new things and ideas
and new directions with the show overall
I am prepared to kind of table that
until shy goood takes over the role
because bring tenant back it's going to
be more nostalgic it's going to
deliberately feel more like the old
stuff so I'm okay with it here that this
is more evocative of his older era but
it feels appropriate for you know
anniversary specials something that is
meant to be celebratory something that
is bringing back an old doctor bringing
back an old companion an old Dynamic
like okay I will will let the Nostalgia
sweep me up here when we get to shoy
godwell please give me something newer
than this but for right now this is nice
this is Comfort viewing this is this is
a warm hug of an episode and yeah I like
it it'd be an overstatement for me to
say that I love it but I do like it and
I'll be curious to see what the next one
brings cuz my suspicion is that this one
is meant to be you the warm
reintroduction and things are going to
get a bit darker next time we'll
see um but those are my thoughts on the
star Beast it's a good time couple of
notes on some of the specifics but
overall yeah this had an energy that I
was happy to exist in for an
hour what did you think about this
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon pays the bills and
is why I'm able to do this as my living
I'm sorry that I got this out um a
little bit later than I had wanted to I
had a very busy weekend um but I will
try to have these reviews out by Sunday
um you know the day following their
airing I can't promise that but that is
my goal I'm hoping that this is the only
one that's going to be out on a Monday
but uh also as a reminder and a heads up
this does mean that I'm not currently
planning on doing the normal Saturday
videos for the next couple weeks because
I have to do quick turn on this
additional videos might happen if
something comes up and I have thoughts
or whatever else but that is the current
plan so stick around like share
subscribe those help me out if you are
already supporting me on the patreon or
you can't afford it that's fair too but
what I really want you to remember is
that you are
beautiful you are
valid and you are
loved you are the council I am just
running the meetings and until next time
this coun
is
adjourned time to thank some patrons and
this time I'm going to say their names
as if I'm greeting them welcoming them
to a party Robin Moore zumin Lula God
Salida tck the thing that goes do in the
anime Ruth goer the goeran Oliver B
solitary pictures rrick Bogden Melinda
Walter
Jen Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks forab
likes the poodle Robin Powell TLO Tracy
scrapit angry Casper Dave Hall Roselyn
Bennett have fun tonight and thank you
for your support I don't know why I
decided to do that this time but I don't
know I'm having
[Music]
fun
no